حسنًا، دعنا نذهب الآن إلى تمارا الراعي
في الأردن، وهي المتحدثة باسم
وكالة غوث وتشغيل
اللاجئين الفلسطينيين التابعة للأمم المتحدة. لقد نظرت
إلى الكثير من هذه الصور من هذه
المدرسة في مخيم جباليا للاجئين، إنها
ببساطة مروعة، هذا هو  مكان
يستخدم كمأوى تقول إسرائيل إنها
تبحث في الأمر أه لكنها قالت إنهم قاموا بالفعل
بأنشطة في المنطقة
أردت فقط رد فعلك على تلك
الصور أولاً، لقد شعرنا بالرعب
عندما بدأ تدفق اللقطات
بالأمس تعرفنا عليه  أن
هذه كانت إحدى مدارسنا، وأدركنا أيضًا
أن هذه كانت إحدى
المدارس في الجزء الشمالي من قطاع غزة
والتي تم استخدامها كمأوى
لآلاف الأشخاص الذين نزحوا
من منازلهم، لذلك شعرنا
بالغضب الشديد من الصور الأولية
ونقوم بالتحقق بما في ذلك أه
مقابلة الشهود لنتمكن من
إعادة ما حدث بالضبط في
هذه الأثناء الهلال الأحمر الفلسطيني يقول القطاع الصحي
بشكل عام في غزة على حد تعبيره أه متجه
للانهيار التام يقولون 95% من
سيارات الإسعاف خارج الخدمة  إما أه
من خلال القصف أو نفاد الوقود
وجميع مرافق المرضى الداخليين
في الشمال تقريبًا غير قادرة على
العمل. مدى يأس
الوضع في جميع أنحاء
القطاع مايكل إنه يائس للغاية،
القطاع الصحي برمته
على وشك الانهيار، لذلك نحن  نحن نتحدث عن
الطوارئ أه الصحة مثل أه
الخدمات والعمليات الجراحية في
آسفيا والمستشفيات الأخرى ولكننا
نتحدث أيضًا عن الخدمات الروتينية في
مراكز الصحة الأولية حتى يتمكن الأشخاص العاديون من
الوصول إلى أدوية
مرض السكري أو ارتفاع ضغط الدم
القطاع الصحي بأكمله على
وشك الانهيار في جميع أنحاء قطاع غزة
على وجه التحديد بسبب نقص الأدوية
ولكن عدم قدرة هذه
المراكز الصحية أه على العمل رغم أن
مراكز صحة الأمم المتحدة أه
تعمل بشكل أقل أه مع انخفاض عدد
الموظفين وتقليل ساعات العمل و  لدينا
عيادات متنقلة تدور حول أه
الملاجئ إذا كان لدينا ما يكفي من الوقود الوقود هو
محور عدم قدرة
القطاع الصحي على مواصلة عمله
وكذلك عدم توفر
الأدوية الكافية وسلامة
الكوادر الصحية لقد رأينا أم  إسرائيلية إسرائيلية
تسقط هذه المنشورات تخبر
أولئك الموجودين في الجنوب حيث قيل لهم
أن يهربوا إلى أه للذهاب إلى الملاجئ أعني
ما هي الملاجئ وأين ينتقل مليون شخص
من الشمال إلى الجنوب أين
ما يقرب من مليوني شخص من المفترض أن
يذهبوا بالضبط 2 مليون شخص  إنهم
نازحون، أي ما يقرب من جميع
سكان غزة البالغ عددهم 2.2 مليون نسمة، وقد طُلب منهم
الذهاب إلى الجنوب بحثًا عن الأمان، لكن الصراع
والضربات الجوية
مستمر في الجنوب، كما
أننا في UNAA لدينا
7070 من مبانينا مميزة بوضوح
باللون الأزرق  أحيانًا ما يتعرض علم الأمم المتحدة وشعار الأمم المتحدة للضرب
المباشر مع
النازحين داخل ملجأنا، لذا
لا يوجد مكان آمن في
غزة